Thanks it's really great to be here on
so PI data is a really fun conference
and over the last five years it's grown
immensely and one thing that happens
when you have a whole bunch of new
people come into a community is that
they may not know the history and may
not know all the little details and
things and so what I decided to do with
my keynote today was take advantage of
this and give kind of a PI data 101 sort
of all the things that you may have
missed if you're new to the PI data
community and kind of give you some
context about where you can where you
can start if you're just coming in into
this or what packages of what tools you
can look into and as you go out and do
do the work that you have that you want
to do in Python so a little bit about me
and Jake VDP you can find me most places
on the internet under that handle and
the most important thing to know about
me is these little weenies right here
they've recently replaced Python as my
favorite thing to talk about so feel
free to ask questions they're amazing
but in the Python world I do I do a
number of things I have this blog that
is being updated
much more rarely these days but kind of
fun Python blog I've contributed to Syfy
and scikit-learn in a scope I and other
packages in the space and I have a few
books on Python and on statistics and
astronomy and astrophysics and things
like that so you can you can check some
of those out I'm from the East science
Institute which is a short little hop
across Lake Washington from here and
it's super convenient because you know
getting here from there is only slightly
longer than flying from San Francisco
given Seattle traffic so I got here in
like just under three hours today it was
great and we're funded by these three
organizations the Moore Foundation the
sloan foundation in the Washington
Research Foundation so I always want to
shout out to them because their generous
funding has been really helpful in kind
of and supporting a lot of the Python
open-source work I've done in the last
few years so thanks to them so when I
met when I'm at the u-dub a lot of
Python training and I talked to a lot of
students who are getting started and I
hear all these sorts of questions over
and over
again you know what is Jupiter how do I
load a CSB how should I install Python
how do I make my code fast just like
endless endless questions and and
there's so many resources out there
there's you can find answers to all
these on the internet but it's it's hard
to find like one place where you can get
these answers so my my audacious goal
today is to answer all these questions
and more for you in about 40 minutes and
those questions boil down to basically
these two things why is the PI data
space the way it is like why why is the
collection of packages and tools and
everything the way it is right now and
that gets back to some of the history of
how we've gotten to where we are and
then also what is the best tool for the
job and that's more about just having
kind of a catalog of associations if I
want to do this thing I should look at
this tool so I'm going to do two parts
of this talk first I'm going to delve
into the history of how the PI data
ecosystem got here and then I'm just
going to do a quick survey of what I
think of is the most important kind of
fundamental tools in the ecosystem so
one thing to realize is go into the
history of PI data's Python is not a
data science language and this is this
is something that comes to the forefront
and all of these issues we look at where
Python came from it was created by this
gentleman Guido van Rossum and it was
created in the 80s and he he made it
basically as a teaching language he
wanted a good language to teach
undergrads and also he wanted to bridge
the gap between the shell and see
basically say that we want to make
things a little bit easier to use on
UNIX systems and it's interesting if you
look if you ask him about what he
thought Python would do he thought we'd
be writing maybe a dozen or a few dozen
line scripts and these days Python there
applications with thousands or tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
lines I mean Instagram runs on Python
right and all these other other
companies so it's amazing where Python
has come given that it wasn't really
designed to do any of that from the from
the beginning so really the question
answer is how did Python become this
sort of data science powerhouse given
that it wasn't designed to do that in
the begin
and so I I want to I want to kind of
dial back and talk about where Python
was and certain certain earlier eras
before we are now and this is this is
kind of the way that I think about it
and in the 1990s I think of Python and
science and data is sort of the
scripting era right and the motto might
be Python is an alternative to bash
right no one wants to code in bash
so let's code in Python instead and
that's where we were in the 90s and you
have interesting effects of that and one
of the one of the people who is working
in the scientific space at that point
was this guy named David Beasley who you
may know if you if you may know from the
Python cookbook and other things but he
was working as in a research lab back in
the in the 1990s he wrote this
interesting paper about the about
scientific computing in Python where he
basically said that scientists are using
all these different tools and they're
they tend to use homegrown software to
implement their own domain-specific
languages or command-line interfaces to
put them together and in this paper he
argued why don't we just use Python to
stitch all these tools together and he
gave a case study of some project he'd
been working on for about four years
using Python as kind of this glue to
script together a bunch of other tools
and he wrote this he wrote this library
that was really influential at that time
the swigs simplified wrapper and
interface generator that could basically
parse some entire Fortran or C code and
generate a Python interface for you so
you don't have to write Fortran or C
anymore to drive your code and this a
lot of the early Sai PI and PI data
tools were built on swig my first
contribution the scikit-learn was a C++
code wrapped with swig and later on we
abandoned swig and moved aside on but
that's another story so in the 2000s
after that I think I think of the 2000s
is sort of the sci-fi era and if there's
a motto for what Python in science was
in the 2000s it's Python is an
alternative to MATLAB right for many
reasons and I see some knowing nods in
the audience that
yeah there's many reasons and if you
look at some of the people who are
influential in the early 2000s and
developing the Syfy stack you can see
this sort of common thread so John
Hunter was the creator of matplotlib and
a few weeks before he passed away in
2012 he gave this amazing Syfy keynote
that I've honestly I've gone back and
watched like four or five times but he
talks about pre Python yeah this
hodgepodge of work process Perl scripts
that call C++
he had MATLAB and he got tired of MATLAB
and noting it and started loading things
into a new plot and this is what
inspired him to build matplotlib
which is basically a MATLAB replacement
in Python in this language that he
wanted to use rather than all this
hodgepodge of other languages
similarly this guy Travis elephant he's
he's founded continuum and previous to
that is wrote the the numpy and Syfy
projects and he says prior to Python to
use pearl and then MATLAB shell scripts
Fortran C plus plus libraries he said
when I discovered Python I really liked
the language but it was nation Mason and
lacked a lot of libraries I felt like I
could add value to the world by
connecting low level libraries to high
level usage in Python so this is what
inspired Syfy now Syfy was this
replacement for MATLAB Fortran shell
scripts and he wrote that with that in
mind and similarly if you if you know
the ipython projects or the the Jupiter
project this is Fernando Perez he
created ipython and he had a similar
hodgepodge of tools C C++ UNIX awk said
SH Perl IDL Mathematica make you know
this is this is this is like horrible to
think about what science was like before
Python but what he did is he built this
ipython project because he wanted
something that was sort of IDL like or
Mathematica like in in the Python space
so he could use just a single tool to
replace all views so you have all these
tools that came out in early 2000s that
basically had the same goal all of them
in the early days they wanted to have
they wanted to be the replacement for
MATLAB or the replacement for these
these combined package
and they all had if you look in the
early code they all had elements of
visualization they had elements of
computation and shell I mean if you look
at matplotlib you can still import the
EM lab sub module that has things like
computing periodic Rams and things like
this there's still computation in MATLAB
more matplotlib even though now a lot of
this has been moved out and the
libraries we know today matplotlib Syfy
and ipython are very very distinct in
what their goals are so it's been an
evolution in the community that way and
so the key conference series I think of
for the sci-fi era is the side PI
conference so these are all the side PI
logos I could find online I look for the
ones before 2008 but they don't seem to
exist according to Google anyway so the
sci-fi conference is really driven a lot
of that innovation since 2002 and up to
today a few people I know in this room
are going to be at Syfy Austin next week
it's always a really fun conference and
I'd recommend attending if you have if
you ever have a chance so after the 90s
the scripting area in the Syfy I think
of the 2010s is the PI data era alright
and if there's a motto for the PI data
era it's like let's use Python as an
alternative to our right so and I think
we're doing we're doing pretty well as a
PI data community of offering that
there's still a few things that are does
really well that we've not matched I
think one is breadth of statistical
routines another is visualization but a
few of us are working on an answer to
that so the PI data it is typifies by
West McKinney and his package pandas and
his book Python for data analysis so
this is what he says in the intro to his
book I had a distinct set of
requirements that were not well
addressed by any single tool data
structures with labeled axes integrated
time series functionality flexible
handing or arithmetic operations and
reductions flexible handing of missing
data merged in relational operations and
I wanted to be able to do all these
things in one place preferably in a
language well-suited to general purpose
software development so this inspired
pandas and I would say arguably we would
not be sitting here today if it weren't
for the pandas library and what
West did and when was that 2009 to 2011
or so when he quit his day job and ate
ramen for two years so he could work on
pandas all day so if you ever see West
thank him for that because I think he
has really done a huge huge thing for
our community there but there's other
key software that's come out and in this
era you know pandas and I think the
first big release was around 2011
scikit-learn had a big it had an early
early guys in 2007 but the kind of main
thing main scikit-learn release was 2009
or 2010
kondeh for packaging it came around in
2012 and really changed the way that I
work in Python changed the way a lot of
people do things the ipython notebook in
2012 and later on the ipython project
was rebranded to Jupiter and the Jupiter
project has really pushed forward what
the way that we interact with code
particularly in this community and of
course the key conference series is PI
data right you're sitting right here and
the early PI data workshop in 2012 this
was a one day thing at Google and
Mountain View and I hide it as close to
my heart because my first public Python
talk was at that workshop at that PI
data 2012 I get a given one hour
tutorial on scikit-learn and from there
I was hooked and I've been trying to
attend as many of these conferences as
possible after 2012 they got their
branding in order and they've been
pretty consistent Spencer but yeah pi
day is it PI data's have been all over
the world and it's been this this
conference series that really is pushed
forward this I think of this data
science as something distinct then maybe
scientific computing which is what the
Syfy era was all about and of course all
these eras are concurrent right now you
know there's people using Python for
scripting there's people using the Syfy
tools there's people using the PI data
era but this is a way that I like to
organize in my mind
how we've gotten to where we are and
that helps you figure out why the tools
are the way they are right and really
the overarching theme is people want to
use Python because of its intuitiveness
its beauty its philosophy its
readability Python gets a lot of lot of
Burt's from other languages because it's
fun to write and so people what people
do is they build Python packages that
incorporate lessons learned in other
tools and communities you know Wes
specifically wrote pandas because he
wanted to do what our does with data
frames John Hunter specifically wrote
matplotlib because he wanted to do
MATLAB style plotting without having to
pay for a MATLAB license you know we're
really Python is good at extracting
knowledge from other tools and other
domains and putting them into our own
space and then running with them right
and Python we've also developed a lot of
interesting things of our own like for
example scikit-learn i think is across
any language it's kind of the premier
way of thinking about machine learning
at least how to interface to machine
learning and how to do machine learning
api's I would argue that no other
language has anything that's as as
succinct and as well thought out as
scikit-learn
so what but we have to recognize the
whole time through this with Python
again is not a data science language and
that adds some adds a little bit of it
adds a little bit of complexity at times
right so python is this general-purpose
language and I actually would argue that
the general-purpose nature of Python is
one of its strengths you know Python you
can think of it as a Swiss Army knife
you have you have Python you can do all
these different things with it you can
do web programming and Django you can
you know do all the backend stuff you
can do front-end type stuff but over the
years as people more and more people use
this the Swiss Army knife gets a little
bit complicated right oh yeah all these
little tools that we have to choose
which one and you got to remember the
order of them so you can find the one
you want and the strength here is that
there's this huge space of capability of
what we can do in Python but the
weakness is like where do you start you
know I I deeply empathize with new users
who say I want to learn Python right now
and they go out there and the universe
is so huge there's so many packages and
so many things that you have to learn
and so many so many little unwritten
pieces of knowledge that are passed from
person to person
that it can be tough to break into it so
with that kind of historical perspective
of the PI data community I want to jump
now into taking a quick tour of the PI
data world some of the tools that you've
probably used maybe if you're newer to
the community you may not have used them
but these I'm just going to give a quick
summary of what I think of the essential
tools today in the PI data world so for
installation I would recommend going
with Conda so Conda is this basically
you can think about it as a cross
platform package manager' similar to an
apt-get or yum or a homebrew or a mac
ports type thing but it works similarly
on Linux OS X Windows and lets you
install packages everything you need in
basically one click or or one
command-line argument so it comes in two
flavors there's Mini Conda which is just
the Installer and anaconda which is the
installer plus hundreds of packages that
continuum thinks you would like and so I
recommend mini Conda because you can get
started as a 25 megabyte download and
you can start installing what what you
need so if you go to the website you
click on the installer for your platform
it's pretty easy and then you run it at
the command line there are ways to do
this through a graphical user interface
as well and once you have that you have
this program called Conda that has its
own Python installation with it so you
have your Python is now connected to
Conda you've completely divorced
yourself from your system Python or from
any other Python installations and then
you can run commands like Conda install
and just essentially type the names of
the packages that you want and
everything all the dependencies will be
managed and it's a really really nice
system if any of you were around the
Python scientific world previous to
twenty twelve previous to Conda things
were way more painful especially if you
were in a setting where you were trying
to get a roomful of people
all to get tools on their laptops and
they had mac and OS X and Windows and it
was I'm glad we're not there anymore it
was a bad time
dark times the other thing that's
amazing about Conda is you can create
environments that are basically like
sandbox environments to try out new
things so if you do conduct create minus
n that means the name I'm going to call
this pi to 7 I tell it what version of
Python I want what version of the
packages I want and it creates this new
environment and once you activate that
environment you have a brand-new Python
executable you have a brand-new set of
core packages that go with that
executable and you can start using it
without breaking your other things so I
use this this all the time I have this
is just the first few environments on my
machine I think I have like 70 or 80
because every time I'm developing a
package you can see some of them here
whenever I'm developing a scikit-learn
package I switch to scikit-learn dev and
install from master and do the
development work there and then when I
need my code to work and not use
bleeding edge stuff that might be broken
on master I just switch back to my
Python 3.6 environment right and you can
switch seamlessly back and forth between
different Python versions this way so
Conda is huge I would I would start
there and if if you've heard about this
pip thing there's a little like hip
verse Conda pip is another installer for
Python packages it links up to the the
Python package index briefly I the
distinction as PIP is something that
installs Python packages only and then
can install them in any environment
Conda is something that can install any
package you can you can install node you
can install our packages you can install
anything but it only installs them
within Conda environments so that's
that's the distinction I would I would
think about if you want to read like
three thousand words on Conda versus PIP
I reference this blog post right here
that I did a little while ago so for
your coding environment once you have
everything installed you can once you
have Conda installed you can install
Jupiter and the Jupiter notebook and if
you've not seen this this is huge this
was introduced in around 2012 actually
the first time I heard about the
notebook was at that PI date at 2012
meetup I gave my little my scikit-learn
tutorial using a web page and a terminal
and like all these different windows and
well I was given the tutorial Fernando
Perez was in the audience
he was typing up my entire tutorial into
a notebook it would just been released
like two months earlier and he came up
after the talk and he's like hi I'm
Fernando have you heard of the notebook
and and he gave me my tutorial in
ipython notebook form at the end of the
hour and I've never looked back every
tutorial since then has been has been in
a notebook because it's amazing so what
you can do is you run the stupider
notebook and then you have this
web-based platform that's like kind of
like a file system access through your
browser and you create a new notebook
and then you have an interface where you
can start running code trying different
things you can even embed graphics
inline and you can do you can do a lot
with notebooks actually the the Python
data science handbook that I recently
published I wrote the entire thing in
the form of Jupiter notebooks so it's
like it's almost like a publishing
platform and if you don't feel like
buying the book you can go to my github
repository and all the notebooks are
there if you feel like you know helping
out my my kids college fund you can buy
the book but and as of this summer
actually I think there's going to be
some a release today maybe even I was
talking to the duper lab folks there's
this Jupiter lab project which is like
the next iteration of Jupiter notebooks
and you can think about it is like
bringing the notebook into the future
where you have a full IDE with text
editor and file viewers and and things
like this and I'm really really excited
for what Jupiter lab is going to do for
our community and I anticipate you know
all my work is going to be in Jupiter
lab within a within a couple months it's
a really cool project that's coming
together so that's the coding
environment and installation what about
numerical computation if you want to do
fast numerix in Python everything
depends on numpy and yes it's pronounced
numpy not numpy
everything depends on numpy it's uh if
you use pandas or can you second learn
or if use any of these other libraries
they tend to tend to base on numpy and
use everything there so you can Kanta
install numpy and then what you have in
dump is is a way to create arrays that
you can interact with really efficiently
so you can create rate arrays you can do
element wise operations on them so here
if you do X x - it actually multiplies
each element of the array x - if you
take a Python list and do x - it doubles
the length of the list right and then
adds all those extra elements because
it's you know pythons design not for
data science that's designed for
something different so we have these
data science tools that we put on top of
it and you can do things like linear
algebra here is taking the singular
value decomposition of a random matrix
you can do random number generation of
different things here down here is a
some standard standard normal random
numbers we've taken the fast Fourier
transform so a lot of these sort of core
numeric operations you want to do in
Python are implemented in numpy and
they're done really really really
efficiently so an example of this is if
you're coming from a language like C or
Fortran or c-sharp or one of these
compiled languages you might be used to
doing things sort of by hands right so
if you want to take an array of numbers
and multiply them all by two and add one
you might be tempted to write a for loop
like this right that's how you would do
it and see if you were writing C code
but this is in Python this is a really
stinkin slow write this takes six
seconds to do some basic inner basic
arithmetic on what is that 10 million
values so this comes down to a number of
reasons but basically it's because
python is interpreted and dynamically
typed and you can get into the weeds
about what that means but the Python
implementation see Python that you're
that most people use is not great for
doing repeated numeric operations
because that's do a lot of type
inference but if you're using numpy you
can write this much more succinctly and
you can do it a lot quicker rather than
six seconds this is taking 60
milliseconds and the way it does that
is that the the numpy arrays know about
the types of the values and so it kind
of pushes those loops down into compiled
code where the type inference doesn't
have to be done ten million times the
type inference is done once on the on
operation so anytime you want to use do
fast numerix and python think about this
sort of vectorization thing if you're
ever writing for loops over large data
arrays you there's probably a faster way
to implement your code and if you want
to if you want a more complete intro to
vectorization and various guises that
takes under in the numpy world you can I
did this talk a couple years ago at
PyCon 2015 you can look up the video to
that okay it's a labeled data we talked
about how pandas sort of opened the PI
data era right so pandas is this routine
is this library that essentially
implements data frames and relational
operators in Python so it's similar to a
numpy array where you have you have
types data in these dense arrays but
data frames have labeled columns and
labeled indices and it looks kind of
like this and you and you can add
columns to the data frame using pythons
slicing Zoar indexing syntax and you can
do things like loading data from disk in
a really really seamless way in a way
that that automatically infers all the
types of the columns so if you're ever
if you ever have data on disk and you
want to get it into your Python space
pandas is basically the way to go you
know numpy has some things like load
text and and other loading you you team
Jen from text as anyone ever used Jen
from text it's horrible you never want
to use it pandas pandas basically
superseded all of that and you can do
all sorts of interesting sequel like
grouping operations that are really
quick so here's one where we have a
bunch of IDs and a bunch of values and
pandas lets you do things like say I
want to group by this ID and take
everything with the same ID and sum all
the values with that ID you get a data
frame out that
that gives you exactly what you want and
this is the kind of operation that you
basically can't do in any of the Syfy
Syfy era tools pandas provides that and
that's a that's a new thing new thing is
of what 2010 so yeah pandas is great um
so moving on to like to the
visualization space the if you look at
visualization in Python you probably are
going to come up with matplotlib and
that's because math live is just
battle-tested it's been around since
2002 everybody's used it the Space
Telescope Science Institute that run
with the Hubble Space Telescope through
a whole bunch of resources and do it
back in like 2004 and 2005 and it's like
you you can use it for just about
anything so it looks a lot like MATLAB
if you've used MATLAB that you're
probably very familiar with it and this
and many people treat that as a bug
these days but it was definitely a
feature when it was created right one of
the reasons the Syfy ecosystem was able
to take off is because it was so
seamless to switch from MATLAB to to
Python so as people Bosch Matt Paul live
and it's easy to bash Matt pop lived for
its API and various reasons but I think
it we got to keep the historical
perspective in mind that we wouldn't be
where we are today if matplotlib didn't
have the API that it has right so you
can you can plot things it's easy to
make quite simple plots if you want to
do some other stuff more complicated
things I would I would go beyond
matplotlib these days so if you're if
you're doing like data visualization of
data frames pandas has these really nice
plotting routines built in that look
that produce matplotlib plots without
having to do the matplotlib api so if
you take a data frame and you say data
dot plot scatter and you tell us the two
column names you want to scatter it
gives you exactly the the plot that you
want and you there's no need to fiddle
with the axis labels and things like
this it just just comes out
Seabourn is a similar package this is a
different package that does is designed
for statistical visualization and you
can do really complicated plots and a
few lines of code
you want the types of plots that
Seabourn has so it's a great library to
check out and then beyond MATLAB there's
also libraries like bouquet which gives
a lot more interactive features it can
do lots of lots of different plots I'm
not going to not going to dive too much
into that I just want to let you know
that's out there and you should check it
out
another thing is plotly which is a
similar in spirit to bouquet it renders
renders plots in the browser allows you
to do interactive visualizations and has
a huge gallery of interesting plots that
you can do so there's a lot out there
and if you're if you're an AR user right
we're in the 20 20 era of Python is a
replacement for our the one thing that R
has one thing that our has over Python
that's really nice is the ggplot library
and I think there's nothing in Python
that matches that at this point one
approach to that is this plot 9 library
which essentially gives you GG plots API
to produce matplotlib plots so that's
worth checking out if you're like a GD
plot fan and you want to keep using
Python it's this is not totally mature
and complete yet but I think it's pretty
promising and there's also the Altair
library that I'm not going to talk about
here but you can see some of my other
talks online on that visualization is
really complicated in Python this is a
slide from a library from a talk I gave
at PyCon a few weeks ago and basically
every node and that is some library and
Python used for visualization so if you
want if you want to see 40 minutes of me
talking about this graph you can go on
YouTube and see that so with all that
other way you you might want to do some
like numerical algorithms right so sighs
the is the package for doing numerix and
Sipe I started as a it's a wrapper of
netlist net-lib is a whole bunch of
Fortran libraries that do things like
integration and interpolation and
optimization really really quickly and
efficiently so scifi contains a lot of
these different sub modules that
essentially are wrappers around these
Fortran operations that go really fast
so I can't give examples of all of these
but basic
any numerical operation that you want to
do Syfy will have so like here's an
example we're importing the the special
library which is special functions and
we're importing the optimized library
and we can find the minimum of the first
order bessel function and then plot it
on there so this is the kind of thing
that Syfy does it has especially if
you're a physicist Syfy is great it has
all the routines that you need if you
want to do machine learning I mentioned
scikit-learn this is this is a great
library because of the API and I'll show
you that so imagine you have some 2d
data and you want to fit a machine
learning model and we all know that a
machine learning model is just a fancy
way of fitting a line to data right so
if you're if you're using machine
learning to drive a car you just have a
gigantic parameter space and the line
you're fitting to the data is the one
that makes the car not crash right so
yeah so if you want to fit a line to
data with what scikit-learn you can use
this this model API where you basically
create a model you fit it to your data
and then you can predict the model on
new data and plot it so this is a what a
random forest fit to this data looks
like and then if you want to switch out
and use a different model all you got to
do is change that model implementation
up there
so here I switch from a random forest to
a support vector machine regressor and
all you have to do is change out that
model definition on the top and all the
rest of the code remains the same so
that's that's the benefit of second
learn it gives you a single API that
lets you explore every single basically
important machine learning algorithm out
there without having to write a whole
lot of boilerplate yourself so it's a
nice way to explore these things and I
think that's a real strength of
scikit-learn and there's we actually
wrote a paper about the scikit-learn API
as I think is kind of fun talking about
the the choices that were made in in
defining that in the beginning so if you
want to start doing things in parallel
there's this great library that's maybe
a year or two old now called desk and
desk is really interesting it has if
you're doing something in
hi this is something you might do you
take an array called a you multiply it
by 4 and remember that multiplies all
the elements by 4 you take the minimum
and then you print it right what death
does is it allows you to do the same
thing but rather than actually doing the
computation it just saves the task graph
that defines that computation so when
you when you multiply the array by 4 say
it says I want to multiply this array by
4 and it saves that and it builds up
something like this so we have the data
on the bottom we get the array and then
in five different cores we we make the
array we multiply by 4 we take the
minimum of all those and of course the
minimum of the minimums is the minimum
right so you you desk knows about how
you can it knows about associativity of
these sorts of operations and
aggregations and so in the end what you
end up with is a way to construct this
task graph without doing any
computations and then you can farm that
task graph out to anything that might be
multiple cores on your computer it might
be multiple machines in a cluster it
might be something on you know Amazon
Cloud or or Azure cloud and then at the
end you can compute it and there's
there's some really cool things
happening with tasks in the data science
space there are ways to plug tasks into
the backend of scikit-learn to kind of
do things transparently so you can look
up those sorts of things and its really
nice if you want to optimize code
there's this project that is really
really interesting it's been around for
maybe five or six years but it's called
numba and essentially what it is is it's
a project that takes Python code and
compiles it into LLVM byte code to make
it run really fast and it's really
really seamless so let's say you're
writing a you're writing an algorithm
that has a big for loop in it I told you
that for loops are bad you should use
numpy if possible but some some some
algorithms you can't you can't convert
to vectorize code very easily so if you
have a code like this you know everyone
uses Fibonacci
this takes 2.7 milliseconds to get the
10,000 Fibonacci number all you have to
do is add this number just some time
compiler decorator
it gives you a 500x speed-up in this
code and what it does is it goes through
it actually it goes through and parses
all the Python code in there and
compiles it to LLVM compiles it really
quickly and then for the rest of time
whenever you call that function you get
the fast version of it and there been
some really nice projects built on top
of this for example the data shader
project which is a visualization project
tied to type of bouquet it uses numba in
the backend to do really really fast
visualizations of billions of points you
can see these see these demos where data
shader is used to visualize you know a
billion taxi pickups and you're
scrolling around and zooming and
rendering in real-time that's based on
number in the backend another way to
optimize code is sites on so sites on
something different it's a it's a
superset of the Python language that
allows you to compile Python into fast C
code and so an example of this we take
our same fib function here 2.7 3
milliseconds for for the result if we
run it through sites on this is this % %
site on is a way you can do it inside
the jupiter notebook you get about a 10%
speed-up which okay you know it's sort
of fast and what what it's doing is it's
taking this Python code compiling it to
C code and then running the C code
rather than the Python code but to
really really get the benefit of scythe
on what you need is to add some types so
if you look at the difference here all I
did was say int n at the top and instead
of a B equals zero one I did a seed F
int a equals zero B equals one so now
the compiler knows that these are
integers and it can optimize that code
and you get this 500x speed-up just by
running your code through sites on with
this kind of extra syntactic sugar and
scythe on is a it's an amazing project
the fact that it can do what it does and
if you look at the source code of numpy
Sai pipe and of scikit-learn Astro PI
sin Phi basically any numerical code in
the PI data ecosystem is using scythe on
its core all these tools are built on
top of site
and that's how you get that's how you
get fast numerix in these libraries
that's how you wrap other C libraries
like lib SVM in fact learn you sites on
to interface to those so it's a tool if
you're doing anything beyond the basic
Python development checkout site on
because it's fun
so yeah that's that's the extent of the
tour that I want to give of all these
packages hopefully hopefully was helpful
and I tried to put references throughout
this slide deck if you want to dig in
and get a little bit more and most of
those packages have nice websites with
tutorials and things like this but so
remember as you're using Python and
Python is not a data science language
and sometimes that leads to things that
are a little bit complicated right
sometimes it means that there are a lot
of different ways to do things because
everyone's trying to build their own API
on top of this language that they love
but I think it's also its greatest
strengths right because we can draw from
so many different communities we can use
Python for so many different things
beyond data and data science and you
know we're looking back at these these
different eras of Python development I
think it's interesting but what's most
interesting is thinking about what's
coming in the future right what are the
2020 is going to bring and even though
there are you know lots of challenges to
Python sovereignty in the data area I
would say I'm pretty confident that
Python will remain relevant for the next
ten years because of the the community
and the way that people in the community
keep adapting things that are learned in
other places in the world bringing them
into Python and so I you know I think
all of us are going to be still writing
Python in 2029 but we'll see thanks very
much so this is my contact info
[Applause]
and we we have about 15 minutes maybe
four questions and the like Craig said
there via Twitter and thank ya so my
back okay so like I said tweet at Pi Day
to Seattle I am using very fancy
technology where i refresh the page as
often as I remember and hold on after so
the first question that came in came
from a couple different people you were
talking about numpy yeah
is it gif or Jif I'm gonna I'm gonna be
stayin on that we got picked on so I say
Jeff but I don't know if that's the
answer okay okay uh although I also say
get and not JIT so and I said JPEG not
JPEG so I one of the first ones that
came in was when should I use pandas
instead of sequel when both are possible
well that's a great question so yeah
pandas is is designed to be kind of
basically in core operations and sequels
is a very different thing you know
you're you're writing sequel code that
can be pushed out to huge databases and
do things at scale so in general you
know if your data set fits into memory
then use pandas because it's easy you
don't have to spin up a sequel server
and figure out all these different
things there are some interesting
projects that that are trying to like
take pandas API or something similar to
the pandas API and and attach a sequel
back-end to it so there there's various
approaches approaches to this so you can
look up but for the time being I'd say
that's the dividing line like if you can
fit data into memory use pandas and for
a lot of people that serves their needs
if you can't use if you can't fit your
data into memory and you still want to
use pandas and kind of core Python tools
desk has a pandas layer that lets you
basically do distributed pandas
computation across across data that's
stored on different machines and in
different places so that's something to
look up as well
all right so I the next one I'm gonna go
largely out of order um do you want to
come comment on open science initiatives
any thoughts on open science and how
early I like open science I don't know
so I don't know because there's like
there's like actual trademark open
science initiative but is that but there
was no capital doing the tweet been
cadet that doesn't imply much yeah so
one of the things that I'll just say one
of the things that got me into Python or
that's kept me in Python is the fact
that I was I do a lot of scientific
research and I really think Open
Sciences is the way of the future and
Python allows you to do that it allows
you it's free and open you can you can
put the code out there you don't have to
worry about site licenses for things
like if you're doing your work in MATLAB
or IDL so I I advocate Python partly
because it's so good for open science
especially when I'm in more academic
settings another one in here what about
this deep learning thing I've heard
about yeah well you might know this
little company that's just across the
water called Google I've heard of that
yeah yeah so yeah deep learning in
Python this is one of the areas that
Python I think is really excelling in
the last few years and if you look at at
the deep learning space I think it's you
can make the argument that Python is the
premier language for doing deep learning
a great example that is the Charis
project I was going to put that in here
but I thought it was a little bit too
much so what Kerris does is it kind of
provides a nice clean API that can
target different deep learning backends
and right now I think it targets
tensorflow which is Google's deep
learning code base and also fionna which
is a project that's been around the
Python community for probably a decade
but it's sort of like like rebranded
itself as a deep learning platform
because it can do all the things like
automatic differentiation and stuff that
makes deep learning fast
so if you want to try deep learning in
Python I'd suggest checking out Karis
and there's some really great tutorials
I think there have been some tutorials
at at PyCon and recent PI data is about
how to use
I next one I you said don't write loops
or don't write or loop given numpy does
number to change that advice yeah so as
I mentioned you can you can do some
things in number with for loops and make
them really really fast at this point
they're still using number is a little
bit of an art you know people people
always put up Fibonacci things like I
did and show how it gets a 500x
improvement as soon as you start going
into something that's a little more
complicated that has to access data in
different places and things like this it
gets a it takes a little more trial and
error to get the code going really fast
so I think number number has a lot of
potential and it's been used for it's
been used for some great things already
but if you if you can avoid number and
do something that you know is going to
work really well like numpy
vectorization rather than for loop then
i would say that's the first thing you
should do and if you can't vectorize
things with an umpire there's a reason
if there's like a memory issue and your
vectorization because numpy instantiate
all the all the intermediate results
then go into something like number or
site on is a good option so I met
announcement if you're planning on going
to a different session for talk number
two now's not a bad time to start moving
in that direction I'm going to keep
talking and we're gonna keep doing QA
but you know the next talks are going to
start so I don't want everything to run
late because you were so excited by
these questions but they're great
I so the next one close to my heart does
Python have an equivalent of deep liar
yeah so that's another thing I think
where our winds at this point there's
not as far as I know there's not a good
good deep liar
type implementation in Python but again
this is I think this is one of those
areas where in the coming years you're
going to see Python adapt a little more
and absorb some of those ideas so we'll
see how that happens
Oh a very urgent one cabs are spaces
tabs or spaces I of course follow Pepe
which recommends four spaces and that's
about it I there's another one that you
know maybe we can do apply on a common
end to podcasts in the Python world what
other packages do you recommend just out
in the wild that maybe didn't come up
here but are just fun things to check
out or you know if you listen to talk
press enemy he likes to say you know
what's your favorite thing that nobody's
ever heard of that you love on pipey i
well so I'll mention Altair because it's
my own thing this is a I keep talking
about how how graphics are not up to
speed with our and Python and I think
Altair is going to be a good way to
address that it's essentially a way to
interface Python to the Vega and Vega
light grammars that they're kind of
graphical grammars and they're it's in
the end you end up with a very nice
declarative API for doing statistical
visualization Omar also I think one of
my favorite packages is the MC package
EMC EE and it's a really lightweight way
to do Markov chain Monte Carlo if you're
doing Bayesian inference so if you're
into Bayes stuff check out MC you may be
hinted at this at the end of your talk
but do you have any prediction for what
the 2020s will be the end of your yeah
what the 2020s will be huh I don't know
prediction is hard especially about the
future is that this thing yeah I think
you know 2020 is I think we're going to
see people using Python more and more
for deep learning type things and and if
you know maybe in maybe in 2027 someone
will give this talk and say you know 20
20s were the era of deep learning where
Python was trying to be tensorflow
perfect up here
a topic that you kind of didn't hit but
it does seem pretty important I
what about report publishing you know
what do you do when you know and
specifically you know do you see good
ways the Python integrates the things
like say tableau or do you you know yeah
so there's different aspects of that so
I'm going to go back to the art
community because they've done some
great stuff in this area there's our
markdown which I really really like and
I really wish we had an answer to that
in the Python world because it's just a
nice way to create documents to create
books to create blogs and websites and
there's another thing in the art world
which is shiny which is a way to kind of
create web apps interactive ways to
publish publish your data science
results with graphics and interactions
on the web so I think some of the answer
to that in the Python world is going to
come via Jupiter lab because if you
think about what the notebook is the
notebook does give a lot of these
elements of like creating interactive
visualizations in the browser but right
now they're tied to the notebook and
unless you have the notebook server that
you can run your you can't you can't
view it without the notebook server
right but Jupiter Labs is is giving
these this ability to to pull out
different cells from the notebook and
pull out different pieces of the
analysis so that you could imagine say
running through a whole notebook taking
your last cell that has the interactive
boquete image or the interactive altair
image or whatever and saying I want to
take this and I want to publish it and
you just have that sell out on a web
page with everything in the notebook in
the background where the user can't see
it so there's going to be the ability to
do that another thing that that could be
interesting is that the plotly team just
introduced this package called - that's
also quite quite similar to what shinee
wants to do or what shinee does where
you can create interactive dashboards in
python and then in one click publish
them up to plot leaves server and yeah
of course cost some money to put things
on their server but
but I think it's an interesting package
the package itself is open-source BSD
license so there's no reason you have to
you you have to pay plotly to use it so
it could be interesting I are PI to
question mark speaker our PI - I mean
these were you know I how do you I mean
I think broadly how do you a pipeline
Python alongside other languages so our
PI - is you know yeah this answer for
our you know beaker is a notebook that
does this for many languages what are
your what are your top oh yeah I know of
those tools I don't I don't use them
much because I tend to do everything in
Python but yeah Jupiter is another thing
that allows you to kind of have kernels
and multiple languages I guess I don't
have a good answer for that I apologize
if I have missed anybody think I have
hit all of the pending questions and I
have two different Twitter clients
though it's refreshing
they both tell me we're caught up so
with that let's uh let's go ahead and
thank Jake again
[Applause]